how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wonder where we talked about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we're going to be talking
about the Hulk and the Hulk's feature in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe a lot of
you have been asking me about the Hulk's
feature in the MCU and here's an update
and the best part is we got it from Mark
Ruffalo himself there have been a lot of
rumors going around about what the Hulk
could end up doing in the MCU some even
say that he could end up being the
villain at some point in time and then
we have others that suggest that we may
be getting a Hulk verse will vary
standalone film but as it's been
revealed by Mark Ruffalo he himself has
pitched a movie to Marvel Studios about
what he would like to see from the Hulk
and we'll break it all down but quick
heads up I partnered with my team to do
an ear pods Pro giveaway if you'd like a
chance to win some air pod pros click
the link in the description down below
or in the pin comment down below and of
course subscribe like the video and
comment to enter this week's Funko pop
giveaway so mark ruffalo has already
stated publicly in front of audiences
and in interviews that he would like a
couple of things to come from the Hulk
and one is his idea of what could be a
very good Hulk film and that is a movie
about what he calls bulk Bruce Banner
and the Hulk combined this is Professor
Hulk that we saw in Avengers in game
Mark Ruffalo was recently on The Tonight
Show with Jimmy Fallon where he said
that he pitched and is still pitching
this movie about bulk so as you can see
Mark Ruffalo clearly wants the next Hulk
film to be about bulk but this isn't the
first time that he has mentioned this
he's actually mentioned this three times
before at interviews and at Comic Con
panels now we were actually supposed to
get a lot more of how Bruce Banner and
the Hulk combined to make bulk in
Avengers in game but that was cut out of
the movie but according to Mark Ruffalo
he wants a movie that shows all of that
and then what Hulk would do after he
became bulk and after Avengers in game
and I think a lot of people would be
curious to see this as well as long as
they took it in a little bit of a
different direction than they took the
Hulk and Avengers in game a lot of
people were pretty
disappointing that we never saw the Hulk
Hulk out and a film about bulk after
Avengers endgame could give us that
chance but that's not the only type of
Hulk film that Mark Ruffalo said that he
was interested in he also said that he
would be interested in a Hulk vs.
Wolverine film now we've had reports
about this before
Mikey Sutton in the past has mentioned
that Marvel Studios is talking about a
Hulk first Wolverine film especially
considering the fact that Marvel can't
actually do a solo Hulk film given the
rights to the Hulk they have to use the
Hulk in a movie that involves other
heroes and again Mark Ruffalo three
times has expressed his interest in
doing a Wolverine vs. Hulk film at Tokyo
comic-con he mentioned that he was
speaking with Kevin Feige about the
future of the Hulk he said that he was
meeting with Kevin Feige about ideas for
the Hulk's future and then he said Hulk
vs. Wolverine I'd like to see that and
he went on to say I think that would be
a really great combo so right now as the
Hulk stands and the MCU Mark Ruffalo has
pitched Kevin Feige as he stated in his
interview with Jimmy Fallon a movie
about bulk how he became bulk and what
happens to him after Avengers in game
he's also probably already pitched Hulk
vs. Wolverine again he stated three
times in three different interviews or
comic-con panels that he wants a Hulk vs
will Vereen film so Mark Ruffalo is
coming back he's not done with the Hulk
in the MCU and if Marvel decided to
combine a movie about professor Hulk and
Hulk vs. Wolverine we could get the best
of both worlds we could see how bulk
came to be with Bruce Banner and the
Hulk merging together we could see what
his life is like after Avengers and
Gaiman then we could see him Hulk out if
he has to fight Wolverine two of the
most brutal and vicious characters that
Marvel has ever created hashing it out
on screen claws vs. fists the two of
them just absolutely going at it this
would be a perfect Hulk movie and we
could even get Wolverine and it sounds
like this could be exactly what Mark
Ruffalo wants so as it stands right now
that's what Mark Ruffalo is pitching to
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios so the Hulk is not done he
should be back relatively soon what do
you all think about this is this a movie
that you would all like to see let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on
everything relating to the MCU you can
follow me on Twitter for live updates
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof